thank you
[Music]
so uh I think it's right that we take a
moment and we honor the life of uh
Lieutenant Allison Russell Elling she
was a um a paramedic
that had actually been one of the First
Responders at 9 11. oh this is her right
here
and uh randomly when she was just going
to get something to eat around the block
from her house she was just senselessly
stabbed by just a random dude for no
reason what the [ __ ] wait she survived
and like helped Evacuate the 911 Peeps
and then recently she just got stabbed
for no reason yeah what floor oh my God
do you know what four shoes on 911 I
don't know it's like a whole thing
there's a
this sounds cows to me but there's like
this weird thing when like if you're
talking about 9 11 stories and like your
90th floor
or above people like yo but if you're
like yeah I was on the I was on the 50th
floor everyone's like
who says that holy [ __ ] no it's just
it's just not a big deal right honestly
it's just this weird I've I've gone down
this weird Rabbit Hole where like
because you investigate me yeah yeah
because they're like you want to go down
the stairs way too easy right the 90th
whatever the [ __ ] 50 is a base though
still those guys got killed right like
those guys got hit hard so when the
plane went diagonal in the building that
was like 90 or like 88 to like 97th
floor or some [ __ ]
so it's like yeah they have a right to
complain but like that's what happens
among 911 survivors like what for oh
really you're on the [ __ ] 55th floor
who the [ __ ] and obviously obviously if
you're like throwing shade at anybody if
you're throwing shade for anybody in
general that was in the building that's
obviously whack but I do understand
giving props to somebody who is [ __ ]
like on the 98. do something that made
it out so there's a cat I read the story
too he was on the 92nd floor and I'm not
kidding this sounds nuts sounds like it
shouldn't have happened he saw one of
the planes coming at the window and he
got down in his desk and he was one of
the only people in his entire office for
that survived the plane went over him no
the the whole room got set on fire and
he just got spared because he like
ducked and covered under like this
certain desk and like when he got up he
said he saw the fuselage the plane it
was like [ __ ] explode he explodes
everywhere fires everywhere he says like
I saw all kinds of [ __ ] up [ __ ] where
he's like then then I booked it for the
stairs and he was one of the few people
too where there's no elevators anymore
in duh because it was like all filled
with plain Fuel and like set on fire so
he's like I found one of those collapsed
pieces of of ceiling and I was able to
like go down into like the lower floors
from there but like otherwise staircases
were [ __ ] everything else got [ __ ]
he was one of the lucky people who got
directed to a certain place got lucky
dude I mean hit the building [ __ ] do
you happen to know if that guy is like
one of those people who got lucky but
then like feels this like immense guilt
probably he sounds like it probably when
he's talking about it it's why but no he
tells the story about do I saw the nose
of the plane hit the building like how
[ __ ] give me a break this is the only
person to see that huh he's one of the
few man that's crazy yeah so uh at the
memorial ceremony everybody was just
like super sad obviously but also
because not only was she a 911 responder
but she also stayed working through
kovid
like for for the ENT EMS uh services and
yeah she was just like a really like a
pillar of that Community yeah and uh she
just literally
wasn't doing anything and just a random
crazy guy ran up to her and just stabbed
her to death
she goes on punished for nothing
yeah that [ __ ] sucks super [ __ ]
sucks I know what it does how old was
she she was
um 60
I should say yeah 60-ish can you say a
full name again so we can remember it it
is Lieutenant Allison Russo Elling she
served for 25 years and she was 61. wow
wow yeah hey Allison Russo
[Applause]
it is really funny and kind of lame when
people do use 911 as a thing when
they're just like that happened to me
when I was selling my motorcycle and uh
and then this kid took it for a test
ride and he didn't come back and I was
like the [ __ ] and I was calling him he's
left I thought I stole it and then his
Dad gives me a call and it's just like
hey uh my son's pretty embarrassed he
dropped your bike a little ways down the
road
um he told me that yeah and he was like
uh by the way I served at 9 11 under New
York fire
did you say wait that was his segue into
it my son dropped your bike and by the
way 90th or [ __ ] off
and I need to get the [ __ ] up tell me
about how he was a father
to use it as a you could trust me he's
gonna bring it back it'll be cool like
everything's fine like I'm up on up and
up and he came back finally and I was
like dude you you don't have to be that
embarrassed like it's fine it's just you
drop your own bike because you bought it
basically and then I told this kid that
hey you know your dad started bringing
up 911 when uh when he called me and
he's like oh God does it all the [ __ ]
time like it was so embarrassing you do
you think he was more embarrassed about
dropping the bikers dad dropping 911
yeah he was more embarrassed by his dad
dropping it's about right it's like a
trust me card yeah that's right you know
what to not go against the I mean go
against the brain dude please don't
I'll give it to that dad you know what I
mean like that's one of those things
context though well okay of course we
weren't there we don't know his story or
the context but 911 is hands down one of
the most [ __ ] impactful things in our
entire generation somebody who's
actually directly a part of it in some
way that contributed to some element of
course of actually being helpful
considering I was in high school and I
like as much sympathy as you you think
you feel or as much as like I'm gonna go
join the Army or whatever and you you
don't it's you know what I mean some of
definitely fewer people actually
participated and did something good I'll
give it to him no I'll give it to him
but then you bring it up to the guy
that's your son is buying I'm just
saying that's a byproduct wow that's the
best product you know what I mean
because it enters that that field of
like if he told you that first and said
hey I serve you 911 is it cool if my son
takes your bike for a ride it just drops
it I don't think I would say yes odd
thing it's just why even bring it up you
got me there yeah
that's like us at bubble mofo last night
it's like hey I started 9 11. can I
order this and it's like what the heck
is for free just it's like dude thank
you thank you for your service a million
percent like completely I I respect I
respect anybody in New York at all like
during that time but then the idea of
like trying to use it kind of taints it
for me a little bit because he tries to
use it yeah and pass it off it makes me
think he's a liar yeah a little bit
because if you're really like I'm not
saying he wasn't but well actually I
kind of am but if if you really were in
911 that way I'm sure you wouldn't be
bringing it up this like
[Music]
they're usually more sad that like
they're the other homies didn't make it
out with them yeah that guy might have
been opposing that's what's sad hey
Cheesecake Factory 50 off the cheesecake
you know they don't do that kind of [ __ ]
and you would think that if something
like that meant so much to your life you
wouldn't want to devalue it in a
situation as worthless as this and pour
it out yeah you know I hate Cheesecake
Factory so I served during 9 11. do I
get 50 off to go
do I have to dine in yeah because on 9
11 it was to go so I hope it's okay with
you guys oh Jesus Anthony's got one
semi-hot take yeah yeah I was at the
airport recently
and uh you know we had like an hour
before our flight and so we went to this
like local Airport Restaurant thing
right I don't [ __ ] remember the name
of it but it just had a bunch of random
stuff I ordered some fries or whatever
right I'm like eating and then a couple
tables down there's like this dress
Decked Out vet with his wife but like he
looked older but not old he's not like
an old guy he's just like an older man
tired he looks a little overweight and a
little bit you know he looks he doesn't
look like he's active but he looks he's
dressed up but I'm not gonna judge and
he's wearing a military uniform full-on
military camo like the whole thing oh
camo yeah camo but he's with his wife
though okay so but whatever regular
civilian pedestrian is that the right
word she have big titties or no yeah I
couldn't see because it was her back to
me it was her back but I was totally
looking for it but I couldn't tell
anyway I forgot to ask these questions
Ryan you have to know and then and then
uh the host comes by and we're in Hawaii
so like you know they're very they're
very nice very I was in Hawaii was he on
a base maybe right there's a ton of
bases yeah maybe right and then uh
she goes and she's like oh how's
everything with my body's trying to
settle up and he's like honestly just
the fries were just terrible uh like it
just it just wasn't good it just wasn't
right and you know it's it's okay
whatever it was just really kind of like
that kind of energy and I could see her
entire emotion because I because I was
watching it the whole time and she's
like oh my God I'm so sorry blah blah
you know really good vibes and she like
walks around she has to go talk to her
manager she comes back to the register
that's right next to us right she's like
doing some stuff she reprints what she
goes back to him hey I took the fries
off but I like really watched the whole
thing and he was like okay thank you
blah blah right the entire time though
and again I'm not making any judgments I
just have my own opinion can you just
judge just tell us what you saw I had
fries I'm eating I'm like
fries these are the best [ __ ] fries
ever no do they finish the fries though
there was no I didn't see anything on
the table like none of the food was
there so I was just they finished the
fries I heard the conversation about I
was like oh man
but I don't know maybe they were bad
fries maybe they got a bad batch but you
were kind of a careful boy a little
guilty boy a little a little bit of you
was
annoying that he was trying to like use
his vet card to get some free fries I
didn't say that man I didn't say it just
because it's in the context of a 911
situation that wasn't on the 9th floor
I'm not saying that I think he was
mixing and matching he's like just give
me sweet potato give me the regular all
right and then he's like oh there's not
good that that good friend I am a
patriot there you are but then again if
we're gonna say that there's veterans
that have done really great stuff we
also have to say that it's a high
probability that there's a small subset
of veterans he said it who take
advantage of these do you think that
they're just like Come What May
what's that mean come what me
me
yeah but yes
[Music]
we can never hit that note
it's an optional note optional
not even my friend again honor to
Lieutenant Allison rooster Elling thank
you for your service rip
um oh yeah [ __ ] the guy who stabbed her
yes absolutely do something about
[ __ ] New York man this is insane hey
but in New York come with me
[Music]
[Music]